aimez vous la musique oui mais vraiment
en amateur oui
surtout comme moyen d'échapper au temps
oui j'aime bien la musique pourquoi ce
premièrement cd las deuxièmement si on
fait la musique classique
actuellement on doit rechercher autre
chose c'est une forme une expression de
l'art une expression de l'homme et ans
de l'homme peut-être vers dieu même
certainement vers dieu c'est un sujet
c'est comme la religion je pense que
c'est très lié non je crois que je suis
insensible depuis mon enfance
quel genre de musique écoutez-vous
orientale le neg l'esprit quelle musique
classique
les gens ont préféré quel est votre
compositeur de jazz préféré à ça je n'ai
pas de compositeurs préférés mais j'ai
des et des musiciens préférés puis c'est
qu'elles sont ils à la cape town et puis
tu fais une telle et telle que c'était
un péché telium sol et pourquoi
aimez-vous le jazz jazz j'ai passé le
rythme que j'aime beaucoup ça vous
excite à l'heure il ya un rythme qui
m'attire beaucoup ça me fait danser
alors ça me fait chier j'aime sentir la
musique je peux sentir déjà ça m'a fait
quelque chose et la musique classique ça
vous fait gagner seul appartement là la
musique classique c'est pour la tête un
peu le jazz et folk ou comment
expliquez-vous l'emprise du jazz sur
l'agenais surtout les jeunes surtout vos
camarades
c'est assez délicat expliquer puisque
certains camarades n'aime pas forcément
le jazz
l'aja c'est une musique qui peut être
musique de mode
oui tandis que certains me la musique
par elle même beaucoup d'autres
préfèrent le jazz pour le temps c'est
parce que la jeunesse de notre époque
est éprise de
rythme et de vitesse quel âge avez-vous
6 9 ans qu'est ce que vous faites dans
la vie je passe mon bac vous passez vos
bacs et ça ne vous gêne pas le jazz pour
les études aussi c'est tout à fait
incompatible personnellement mon
expérience de professeur me fait dire et
je rassure un certain nombre de parents
qui peuvent regarder cette émission et
que j'ai eu de très bons élèves qui
aimait le jazz qui ont été reçus au bac
chaud et des gens qui avaient rugi a été
collé le pas spécialement ils le
supportent sans plus et sans prise on
vous le reproche
dans la mesure où ça me gêne non mais
avoue scolaire oui et ça vous gêne
vraiment dans votre vie scolaire oui
assez c'est à dire que vous placez
combien d'en écouter du jazz en général
une heure ou une heure et demie par jour
tenir g
ok une certaine manière de faire mes
devoirs tout en écoutant de la musique
qu'est ce que le jazz vous empêche
d'étudier oui bah mes parents on dit
plutôt ça ça lui passera passera un jour
ça comme il est un peu comme une maladie
cependant malgré l'opposition des
parents est mal vu les difficultés de
travailler en écoutant du jazz
on achète souvent des disques à la
sortie du lycée
ce disque connaît bien les manic sa
clientèle et quels sont les coûts que
ces jeunes gens eh bien il est partagé
entre le les variétés américaine et le
jazz qui achètent et paillettes
américaine quand on est vous tout
d'abord par rail et américaines
le rock le rock chanté de rock chambéry
qui achètent les disques de rock les
jeunes de 14 ans 15 16 ans à peu près et
à peu près
pour le jazz c'est environ 15 ans à 18
ans dans le rock'n'roll c'est une forme
dérivée c'est c'est une musique
d'ambiance on claque des doigts on crie
on hurle on se détend peut-être on
chahute est-ce que vous pensez que le
rock'n'roll est une image de la violence
de la jeunesse actuelle vendue qu'à de
la violence qu'on lui prête n'en voyons
on a on a dit que les blues en associe
le rock n roll ou blousons noirs
pas du tout je ne crois pas on a fait
une fausse près sur les blousons noirs
car il y a bien entendu aussi plusieurs
catégories allez on pourrait associer
aussi le blouson noir au blazer bleu du
drugstore ouvriers et que pensez-vous de
l' influence du rock'n'roll de johnny
hallyday sur les jeunes
rose mais c'est pas très bon je vais
passer en mode de personnel n'est pas
très bon pourquoi je suis pas de ceux
des garçons qui se réunissent dans un
dans des cafés les écoutes du box et où
est ce que je veux dire non pas
exactement qu'est ce que vous appelez ce
genre de garçon vous ne fréquentez pas
voulu mort pourquoi parce que c'est pas
de fréquentations a way
[Musique]
et les voilà ses danseurs de rock'n'roll
dont on a tant parlé ces fameuses
admirateur de johnny hallyday dont les
rencontres provoque des bagarres
retentissante
alors que vont ils répondre à ceux qui
traitent le rang avec terminé le jazz
moderne très bon ticket pour enfin voir
nous ne sommes pas des connaisseurs mon
avis faut déjà
voir certaines notions musicales
complexe et le jazz new orleans ça se
rapproche plus déjà de ce qu'on aime
c'est plus simple comme un clic vous
aimez la musique de jazz vous l'écoutez
souvent non moins souvent que
par exemple géniale idée vous aimez
johnny hallyday j'aime justin son poids
parce que
il est beau d'abord c'est un bon garçon
champrenault c'est ce qui vous attire
d'abord c'est parce qu'il est beau
garçon
avançons chambre
et qu'est ce qu'on pensait johnny
hallyday johnny hallyday
je n'aime pas les chanteurs de rock
france pourquoi parce que je scénariste
soit dans les limites du
du coup les soigne aussi
j'ai eu la chance en tient une grande
place dans ma poitrine très grande
classe mais pendant que le cinéma
beaucoup plus même
vous écoutez sur les chansons à la radio
j'écoute les émissions de salut les
copains
vous avez un temps 10 d'or j'ai un
transistor et un électrophone oui vous
avez beaucoup de 10 oui je sais une
cinquantaine de disques et parmi ces 50
10 q combien disque de chansons
au bas presque toutes ces sont des
chansons vous avez un chat une chanson
préférée bah je préfère sentimentale par
eddy mitchell est ce que est ce que vous
avez lu même beau parent pour les
chansons en antre du tout mes parents
c'est l'accordéon apens et vous vous
n'avez pas lu tout l'accordéon moi je
les écoute pas y mettre la radio
autrement non je monte dans ma chambre
et j'écoute mes disques à moins l'excusé
vos camarades de saint denis à peu près
en l'air on est même book pro je pense
qu'ils préfèrent eddy mitchell oui c'est
à dire les chansons vieillit l'europe
oui c'est ça et johnny au non moi je ne
prenais pas du tout estrosi france ont
lutté pendant les études évidemment
rumeurs sur or façon oui et ce qui est
une tendance générale oui laquelle
ce n'est pas cet engagement il ya 10 et
vieillit bien entendu ni moi
personnellement continue mais le temps
d'en sont partagés vous discutez avec
les camarades de classe de la chanson
ligne
mais sur des caténaires sur steam
tout cela est bien bien pour quelles
raisons et forme un groupe séparé
secondes et demandé à ses camarades
qu'avec d'autres contre n'est pas à
bompas qu'avec les camardes de la place
vous pouvez dire vous avez tel goût
alors que vous n'avez pas ou se sont
parés à la mode wallace et cela quel âge
avez-vous de 16 ans et vous monsieur
aussi antilles également aux quelles
raisons pour les paroles je veux
addition trop ce qu'est ce que c'est
qu'une chanson coucou c'est nous tout
d'abord les paroles aussi ses études à
part les paroles et quelle est votre
chanson préférée
l'avis d'alain barrière alors quels sont
vos goûts en matière de chanson au chac
bras elle où je devrais le bugue aufray
chante brassens
il offrait aussi je croyais qu'elle quel
âge avez vous eu que 15 ans justement et
que les garçons de 15 ans a adoré les
chansons d'europe et y est on a
forcément mais c'est qu'ils ont un
certain agacement je parle quand elle
entre copains on aime bien quand même
entendre être europe sepa oui et alors
quand aimé vous entendre en rock et
qu'on aime et vous pas entendre un rôle
pour céder et maintenant d'en entendre
en repiquant quand on est nombreux à des
camarades dans une surboum quoi pour
danser quest
une chanson de brassens et
assez intime quand on est deux fois
quand on est tout seul quand on est tout
seul ou avec des ati est ce que vous
écoutez les chansons en même temps que
vos parents oh non quel coût quelle est
la chanson préférée aux parents ont ils
vont faire jean sablon vous voyez et on
peut bien réussir même c'est
mathématique en écoutant une chanson non
seulement si c'est assez facile quoi
plus profond c'est par exemple je peux
pas j'arrive pas à réfléchir en étant
quelques chevaux tandis que vous pouvez
penser aux mathématiques en écoutant une
chanson sa sauvegarde et seulement si
c'est facile à seulement c'est facile
[Musique]